now the second step of parsing our map
involves loading all the tile set data
described in the file for each tile set
we need to create a new image set a
callback function for once it's loaded
and then set the source value to the
tileset's image attribute this is the
same basic image loading process that
we've been using previously it's worth
pointing out now that we're kicking off
asynchronous loads of images for our map
data which already has been
asynchronously loaded as such we may
want to actually wait on setting the
fully loaded flag to true until after
all the images are loaded to do this
you'll need to use a counter variable to
keep track of how many images have been
loaded and only set the fully loaded
flag to true once all the tile sets have
been successfully loaded into memory